but what is it about montessori talk
about that for a second because
it does seem once you get on that
montessori train you
really start to appreciate this like
child let it lead education
yeah it's child led um it's the again
like the focus on the child being able
to
you know follow that follow their path
follow their interests
the fact that folks who are montessori
uh teachers
you know are very well uh trained um and
they're
they're esteemed in the craft of
montessori
um and it also just has a very strong
brand
frankly uh you know a lot of um famous
people
were went to montessori schools yeah a
lot of successful creative individuals
i've gone to montessori schools and so
the belief i had was hey like this is
something that we should make available
to everyone
but again what i've learned is that
education
both from the teacher standpoint and
from the parent standpoint
it's very very personal and uh
and providing options is gonna be
is is very very important similar to
airbnb
right uh yeah and so so that that's what
inspired us
i like the ratings and reviews i see a
couple of testimonials here but how do
you
make sure the ratings and the reviews
are well done because i noticed you
can't click on those you don't see the
details
how do you think about that so the
ratings and reviews are only from
parents that are enrolled
so you can't you can't just go and leave
a like you can't go
drive by right no nope and then um the
testimonials we have to be really
mindful about
because a bad testimonial could ruin
someone but like uh a parent
could you provide and vet these
testimonials or do they post them
the teachers all the parents um uh that
all the parents provide them we um we
actually choose what we share and what
we don't share okay
a little editorial direction exactly and
then when we see a bad one
we work with the provider on it so we'll
go and and spend time with the provider
but we still show the score
so you could leave a one and say i hate
this teacher um we'll show the one
we won't show i hate this teacher and
then we'll go and work with the teacher
to be like why does this parent hate you
and if it's actually something that is
warranted
we might remove the provider from the
platform or we'll work with the provider
to turn it there so
being on the platform is a privilege not
a right
you have to maintain a certain standard
to be on here that's exactly right
what percentage of people are accepted
to the platform
and uh what is your vetting process
how long does that take what does it
cost you to do et cetera
so um what percentage are accepted
so we've actually adjusted our model um
over the
uh since covid and we've uh we found
that our reviews are are so powerful
that we
we do less vetting up front and um we
pro
we rely on um licensing so every
program to be on our platform has to be
licensed by the the
state um that they're in and to get
licensed you have to get background
checked
someone has to go into your home and
inspect your home
and uh all right that's the licensing so
that you can draft off of that
exactly so we rely on that and then once
you get
licensed and you're listed on the
platform we start to track your
performance with reviews from parents
and if we're finding that you're getting
bad reviews you know we step